i think it's very important to have as
many ways as possible to view a certain
type of problem so i want to introduce
you to a different way some people might
have taught this first but the way i
taught it in the first double integral
video is
kind of the way that i always think
about when i do the problems but
sometimes it's more useful to think
about the way i'm about to show you and
maybe you won't see the difference or
maybe you say oh those are just the
exact same things someone actually
emailed me and told me that i should
make it so i could scroll things and i
said oh that's not too hard to do so i
just did that i scrolled my drawing
but anyway let's say we have a surface
in three dimensions it's a function of x
and y you give me a coordinate down here
and i'll tell you how high the surface
is at that point and we want to figure
out the volume under that surface
so
we can very easily figure out the volume
of a very small column
underneath this surface so this this
whole area is is or this whole volume is
what we're trying to figure out right
between the dotted lines i think you can
see it
you have some experience visualizing
this right now
so let's say that i have
a little area here we could call that
d a
let me see if i can draw this
let's say we have a little area down
here
a little square the x y plane
and it's
depending on how you view it this side
of it is dx
its length is dx
and the tight you could say on that side
is d y
right because it's a little small change
in y there and it's a little small
change in x here
and it's area the area of this little
square is going to be dx times dy
and then if we wanted to figure out the
volume of the solid between
this
little area and the surface we could
just multiply this area times the
function right because the height at
this point is going to be the value of
the function roughly at this point right
this is going to be an approximation and
then we're going to take an infinite sum
i think where you know where this is
going
but let me do that let me
let me at least draw the little column
that i want to show you so that's one
end of it
that's another end of it
that's the front end of it
that's the other end of it
so we have a little figure that looks
something like that
a little column
right it intersects the top of the
surface
and the volume of this column
not not too difficult it's going to be
this little area down here which is we
could call that da
sometimes written like that d8 it's a
little bit small area and we're going to
multiply that area times the the height
of this
column and that's the function at that
point so it's f of
f of
x and y
and of course we could have also written
it as
this d a is just dx times dy or dy times
dx i'm going to write it in in every
different way so we could also have
written this as
f of x y
times dx
times dy and of course since
multiplication is associative i could
have also written it as
f of x y
times d y dx these are all equivalent
and these all represent the volume of
this column of that's that's between
this little area here and the surface
so now
if we wanted to figure out
the volume of the entire surface there
was a couple of things we could do we
could add up all the volumes in the x
direction because you know between the
the lower x bound and the upper x bound
and then we'd have kind of a thin
a thin sheet although it'll already have
some depth because we're not adding up
just dx's there's also a dy back there
so we would have a volume of a figure
that would extend from the lower x
all the way to the upper x go back dx dy
it would go back dy and come back here
if we wanted to sum up all the the dx's
and if we wanted to do that which imp
which expression would we use well we
would we would be summing with respect
to x first so we could use this
expression right
and actually we could write it here but
it just becomes confusing if if if we're
summing with respect to x but we have
the d y written here first it's really
not incorrect but it just becomes a
little ambiguous are we summing with
respect to x or y but here we could say
okay if we want to sum up all the dx's
first
let's do that we're taking the sum with
respect to x and let me i'm going to
write down the actual normally just
write numbers here but i'm going to say
well the lower bound here is x is equal
to a
x is equal to a and the upper bound here
is x is equal to b
x is equal to b
and that'll give us the volume of you
could imagine a sheet with depth right
the sheet is going to be parallel to the
x-axis
right and then once we have that sheet
my video i think that's i think that's
the newspaper people trying to sell me
something anyway so once we have this
sheet i'll try to draw it here too i
don't want to get this picture too
muddied up but once we have that sheet
then we could integrate those we could
add up the dys right because this
width right here is still dy we could
add up all the different dys and we
would have the volume of the whole
figure
so once we take this sum
then we can take this sum where y
where y is going from its bottom which
we said was c
from y is equal to c
to y's upper bound to y is equal to d
fair enough and then once we evaluate
this whole thing we have the volume of
this solid or the volume under the
surface
now we could have gone the other way
i know this gets a little bit
messy but i think you get what i'm
saying let's start with that little d a
we had originally
let's start with a little d a instead of
going this way
instead of summing up the d x's and
getting this this sheet let's sum up the
dys first
right so we could take
we're summing in the y direction first
so we would get a sheet that's parallel
to the y axis now so it would the top of
the sheet would look something like
that
right so if we're summing the dys first
we could
we would take the sum we would take the
integral with respect to y and it would
be the lower bound would be y is equal
to
c
and the upper bound is y is equal to d
and then we would have that sheet with a
little depth the depth is dx
and then we could take the sum of all of
those
sorry my throat is dry
i just had a bunch of almonds to get
power to be able to record these videos
but once i have one of these sheets and
if i want to sum up all of the x's then
i can take the infinite sum of
infinitely small columns or in this view
sheets
infinitely small depths
and the lower bound is x is equal to
a and the upper bound is x is equal to b
and once again i would have the volume
of the figure and all i showed you here
is that there's two ways of integra
doing the order of integration
now another way of saying this if this
if this little original square was d a
and this is a shorthand that you'll see
all the time especially in physics
textbooks
is that we are
integrating
along the domain
right because it the xy plane here is
our domain so we're going to do a double
integral a two dimensional integral
we're saying that the domain here is two
dimensional and we're going to take that
over f
of x and y
times d a
i've i and i the reason why i want to
show you this is
you see this in physics books all the
time and i think it's i don't think it's
a great thing to do because it is a
shorthand and maybe it looks simpler but
for me whenever i see something that i
don't know how to compute or that's not
obvious for me to know how to compute it
it actually is more confusing it so i
wanted to just show you that what you
see in this physics book when someone
writes this it's the exact same thing as
this or this the d a could either be dx
times d y or it could either be d y
times d x and when they do this double
integral over domain that's the same
thing as just adding up all of these
squares where we do it here we're very
ordered about it right we go it in the x
direction and then we add all of those
up in the y direction we get the entire
volume or we could go the other way
around when we say that we're just
taking the double integral first of all
that tells us we're doing it in two
dimensions over a domain it leaves it a
little bit ambiguous in terms of how
we're going to sum up all of the da's
and they do it intentionally in physics
books because you don't have to do it
using cartesian coordinates using x's
and y's you could do it in polar
coordinates you could do it a ton of
different ways but i just wanted to show
you that this is another way of having
an intuition of the volume under a
surface and it's these are the exact
same thing as this type of notation that
you might see
in a physics book sometimes they won't
write a domain sometimes they'd write
over a surface
i will later do those integrals here the
surface is easy it's a flat plane but
sometimes it'll end up being a curve or
something like that but anyway i'm
almost out of time i will see you in the
next video